ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行えます
花見0ギー一番東関東に住んでいるすべての人と一緒に新宿業に押し込むせません
ああそれ自分も花見です2番場所をやっと確保したら違うに青いタート惜しく
ますこれで自然に触れずに済むさん
1そこにいる友達を全員無視してインスタの友達とバーチャル花見をする
満開のしだれ桜毎年見てるけど毎年その美しさに驚く
の美しさにびっくりする女子限定その美しさを借りたプロフィール写真を撮ってもらう
ちょっと写ってるアメリカに向け4番とにかく機で
と連発するキレイめっちゃキレイまじきで飲んだこれはめっちゃ綺麗なんだけど
アメリカ人限定
最初から最後まで花見の発音を間違える母の実ってやっぱ楽しい
よな動画花見だ掛けて花見だそう言ってるから
花見5番ちゃんと理解していないのにわびさびについて話す
桜のこの鮮やかに色っていいよなわびさびっぽいっていうか
や道路わびさびっちそういう意味じゃなくて坊主にでもなろうかな
6箱3箱がなくて風が吹いているか
ラとりあえずコンビニおにぎりのベタベタするラップを手で持つそうですね綺麗ですね
ななめ後ろに座っている中国人に何度も何度もぶつかるそうですできるああすみますあ
ok
8番花粉症スムースキューバ近くでギターを弾きながら桜を歌を男子大学生のわざと
らしい声を無視しようとするブーン
喰らう
きっと大魔獣版-6
乾杯11番8もう一回乾杯花火楽しい
12番突然の雨に降られるあーやばい
13番拡管と全体の人口と一緒に新宿駅に殺到する
えっ動い傘傘がさせてますよ14番デー者によってその窓から最多バッグ
ありの桜が落ちていくのを見るそしてその風景をスマホで通り
気取った文書と一緒にインスタに up する今日は新宿御苑で花
花見が苦手だという人もいるけど私はとても好きだ
綺麗な白レザーからを見ながら昔からの友達と話したり手作りのおにぎりを食べたり時
には周りの人たちの楽しそう
ような声を聞いたりしてもちろん今ではいたけれどそれもなんだか
よかったと思う最後にを突然雨が降り出し友達と笑いながら駅に向かってダッシュ
そして今は東西線に乗っていて一瞬にして空っぽになった公園の寂しそうな桜が静かに
落ちていくのを見ている
とてもわびさびらしいちん子だった
阿部さんに買った一日
ni